MARK MERCHANDANI:
We're talking all
about Kubernetes-- coding,
Enterprise functionality,
and serverless.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
We talked about some
of the announcements
at Google Cloud Next.
But there was so
much to show, there's
no way we could fit it
into just one video.
We've compiled a huge list
of announcements for you
to check out and see which ones
you can use to start building
with today.
Speaking of which,
here are some ones
that we're really excited about.
First up is one that
you may have missed--
Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is a set of
plugins for Intelligent
and Visual Studio Code
that brings automation
and assistance to every phase
of the software development
lifecycle, from local
developer environments
right to the cloud.
And with integrated
command line tools,
like Scaffold, Jib, and
kubectl under the hood,
Cloud Code gives
you everything you
need for developing with
Kubernetes and the managed
Google Kubernetes Engine.
Give it a try.
Speaking of managed
Kubernetes, did you
catch the GKE
Advanced announcement?
We've just published
the first blog post
in a series that talks about
what GKE Advanced offers.
Think of it as the GKE
you're already familiar with,
but with a bunch of
Enterprise-requested features,
such as automatic
vertical pod auto-scaling
and node auto-provisioning.
More integrations
and an enhanced SLA
give you the
flexibility to choose
the right level of
managed Kubernetes
and to launch your
application on Google Cloud.
Now, if you're using
Kubernetes to help orchestrate
but you still want
the [INAUDIBLE]
to utilize serverless,
Knative is worth checking out.
Google Developer
Advocate Mete Atamel
has a GitHub repo that
walks you through setting up
GKE with Istio and
Knative, then covers
the three main components--
serving, eventing,
and building.
This is a great way to start
exploring how serverless
can help run your application
without worrying about how
the underlying logistics work.
And best of all-- you get some
hands-on Knative experience.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.